le team
heureusement et six aides en heure avant
au moins deux mois dépasse pas 10 comme
speakerine à ces termes on est coincé
dans ce sens de mecs en faire un film
c'est sur des faits réels sont tout sauf
la vérité malheureusement l'histoire se
répète
planifier notre idée derrière c'était
parce que nous savons qu actuellement
encore
il n'a pas encore été restaurée et rendu
la cassette audio is it more difficult
because you friends
c'était très facile à être dirigée par
georges part il est très intelligent il
est trés et les très gentils et les
trucs humeur tout le temps mais vraiment
il est très sérieux et est complètement
accompli mais des trucs faciles
c'est pas que c'est difficile le
problème c'est qu'il ait pas de déconner
donc on peut se concentrer c'est
compliqué qua non évidemment que c'est
pas difficile c'est il veut il crée une
atmosphère super super agréable super
détendu et parce qu'ils sont justement
bien préparé avant quoi donc taxe les
ferries en fait c'est très facile tu
sais ce qu'il peut se passer sur un
plateau convenait pas avec tes amis
c'est que vous perdez beaucoup de temps
être poli et très diplomate y est cette
sorte de diplomatie artistique et ya un
tas de son de conversations
périphériques aux personnes vraiment ne
va droit taux dépasse qui ne veulent pas
le blesser demeure baissier il est
difficile pour moi de parler la vérité
des lotos des trouvailles avec george
clooney
musulmans et les considère est un pôle
it do you may de la casse des bob bell
et ben ils étaient cruelles savage et
mon sens une commande complète un
challenge tout stigmate bad a fait
malheureusement ce n'était pas du tout
un défi est ce que c'est vraiment très
mauvais oui je voudrais savoir pourquoi
dans cette équipe d'américains vous tuer
l'anglais et le français ok ait aidé tu
veux dire la vérité quand on le voit
arriver dans l'avion voilà qui explose
j'ai deux questions font george clooney
la première c'est que qui nous raconte
l'émotion particulière de diriger son
père ça doit être quand même quelque
chose de deux d'étranges voilà nommé
permettez moi de vous dire simplement
mon père était dans l'armée en allemagne
un set en deux et c'était vraiment drôle
de le ramener en allemagne
je suis très proche de lui qui mieux que
lui pourrait jouer
cet homme âgé de 28 ans
j'ai en fait rien ne change plus
difficile de tous les acteurs a été mon
père parce que nous sommes tous le fils
n'a pas le droit de dire à son père ce
qui doit faire dans monument semaine les
monuments semaines apparaissent
extrêmement soudée je voudrais savoir
comment vous avez constitué le casting
c'était la boisson non carrière est ce
que le tournage à babelsberg a suscité
des réactions dans en allemagne nous
prête à presse et est ce que à la
berlinale comment réagit le public
allemand
mais ça c'est l'accueil le plus
chaleureux que j'ai eu depuis longtemps
pour un film vous ne vous le sentiment
que vraiment bois vers la classe
artistique et c'était très fier du
chemin qu'ils ont fait plus que les
allemands ont fait en fait on a été là
dessus et celui comme vous pensez un peu
à l'histoire de pouvoir qu'il soit là
debout d'europe et il a eu jusqu'à ce
qu'un des ovations de 5h10 c'est
vraiment quelque chose
l'histoire